[Music]
you know my dears
that your mother was an orphan and an
only child
and i dare say you have heard that your
grandfather was a clergyman
up in westmoreland where i come from
i was just a girl in the village school
when one day
your grandmother came in to ask the
mistress if there was any scholar there
who would do for a nursemaid
and mighty proud i was i can tell you
when the mistress called me up
and spoke to my being a good girl at my
needle and a steady honest girl
and one whose parents were very
respectable though they might be poor
i thought i should like nothing better
than to serve the pretty young lady
who was blushing as deep as i was as she
spoke of the coming baby
and what i should have to do with it
however
i see you don't care so much for this
part of my story
as for what you think is to come so i'll
tell you at once
i was engaged and settled at the
parsonage before miss rosamund
that was the baby who is now your mother
was born
to be sure i had little enough to do
with her when she came
for she was never out of her mother's
arms and slept by her all night long
and proud enough was i sometimes when
mrs trusted her to me
there never was such a baby before or
since
though you've all of you been fine
enough in your turns but for sweet
winning ways
you've none of you come up to your
mother she took after her mother
who was a real lady born a miss fernival
a granddaughter of lord fernivals in
northumberland
i believe she had neither brother nor
sister and had been brought up in my
lord's family till she had married your
grandfather
who was just a curate son to a
shopkeeper in carlisle
but a clever fine gentleman as ever was
and one who was a right down hard worker
in his parish which was very
wide and scattered all abroad over the
westmoreland fells
when your mother little miss rosamund
was about four or five years old
both her parents died in a fortnight one
after the other
ah that was a sad time my pretty young
mistress in me was looking for another
baby
when my master came home from one of his
long rides
wet and tired and took the fever he died
of
and then she never held up her head
again but live just to see her dead baby
and have it laid on her breast before
she side away her life
my mistress had asked me on her deathbed
never to leave miss rosamund
but if she had never spoken a word i
would have gone with a little child to
the end of the world
the next thing and before we had well
stilled our sobs
the executors and guardians came to
settle the affairs
they were my poor young mistress's own
cousin lord fernival
and mr esthwaite my master's brother a
shopkeeper in manchester
not so well to do then as he was
afterwards and with a large family
rising about him
well i don't know if it were their
settling or because of a letter my
mistress wrote on her deathbed to her
cousin my lord
but somehow it was settled that miss
rosamond and me were to go to fernival
manor house in northumberland
and my lord spoke as if it had been her
mother's wish that she should live with
his family
and as if he had no objections for that
one or two more or less could make no
difference and so grand a household
so though that was not the way in which
i should have wished the coming of my
bright and pretty pet to have been
looked at
who was like a sunbeam in any family be
it ever so grand
i was well pleased that all the folks in
the dale should stare and admire
when they heard i was going to be the
young lady's maid at my lord fernival's
at fernandal manor
but i made a mistake in thinking we were
to go and live where my lord did
it turned out that the family had left
fernival manor house 50 years or more
i could not hear that my poor young
mistress had ever been there though she
had been brought up in the family
and i was sorry for that for i should
have liked miss rosamond's youth to have
passed where her mothers had been
my lord's gentleman from whom i asked as
many questions as i could
said that the manor house was at the
foot of the cumberland fells
and a very grand place that an old miss
fernival
a great aunt of my lords lived there
with only a few servants
but that it was a very healthy place and
my lord had thought that it would suit
miss rosamond very well for a few years
and that her being there might perhaps
amuse his old aunt
i was bidden by my lord to have miss
rosman's things ready by a certain day
he was a stern proud man as they say all
the lord's fernival were
and he never spoke a word more than was
necessary
folk did say he had loved my young
mistress but that because she knew that
his father would object she would never
listen to him
and married esthwaite but i don't know
he never married at any rate
but he never took much notice of miss
rosamund which i thought he might have
done
if he had cared for her dead mother he
sent his gentleman with us to the manor
house
telling him to join him at newcastle
that same evening so there was no great
length of time for him to make us known
to all the strangers before he too shook
us off
and we were left two lonely young things
i was not 18
in the great old manor house it seems
like yesterday that we drove there
we had left our own dear parsonage very
early and we had both cried as if our
hearts would break
though we were traveling in my lord's
carriage which i thought so much of once
and now it was long past noon on a
september day and we stopped to change
horses for the last time
at a little smoky town all full of
colliers and miners
miss rosamund had fallen asleep but mr
henry told me to waken her
that she might see the park in the manor
house as we drove up
i thought it rather a pity but i did
what he bade me
for fear he should complain of me to my
lord
we had left all signs of a town or even
a village
and were then inside the gates of a
large wild park
not like the parks here in the south but
with rocks and the noise of running
water
and gnarled thorn trees and old oaks all
white and peeled with age
the road went up about two miles and
then we saw a great and stately house
with many trees close around it so close
that in some places their branches
dragged against the walls when the wind
blew
and some hung broken down for no one
seemed to take much charge of the place
to lop the wood or to keep the
moss-covered carriageway in order
only in front of the house all was clear
the great oval drive was without a weed
and neither tree nor creeper was allowed
to grow over the long many windowed
front
at both sides of which a wing projected
which were each the ends of other side
fronts
for the house although it was so
desolate was even grander than i
expected
behind it rose the fells which seemed
unenclosed and bare enough
and on the left hand of the house as you
stood facing it
was a little old-fashioned flower garden
as i found out afterwards
a door opened out upon it from the west
front it had been scooped out of the
thick dark wood for some old lady
fernival
but the branches of the great forest
trees had grown and overshadowed it
again
and there were very few flowers that
would live there at that time
when we drove up to the great front
entrance and went into the hall
i thought we should be lost it was so
large and vast and grand
there was a chandelier all of bronze
hung down from the middle of the ceiling
and i had never seen one before and
looked at it all in amazement
then at one end of the hall was a great
fireplace
as large as the sides of the houses in
my country with massey and irons and
dogs to hold the wood
and by it were heavy old-fashioned sofas
at the opposite end of the hall to the
left as you went in on the western side
was an organ built into the wall and so
large that it filled up the best part of
that end
beyond it on the same side was a door
and opposite on each side of the
fireplace
were also doors leading to the east
front but those i never went through
as long as i stayed in the house so i
can't tell you what lay beyond
the afternoon was closing in and the
hall which had no fire lighted in it
looked dark and gloomy but we did not
stay there a moment
the old servant who had opened the door
for us bowed to mr henry
and took us in through the door at the
further side of the great organ
and led us through several smaller halls
and passages into the west drawing room
where he said that miss fernival was
sitting poor little miss rosamund held
very tight to me
as if she were scared and lost in that
great place and as for myself
i was not much better the west drawing
room was very cheerful looking with a
warm fire in it
and plenty of good comfortable furniture
about
miss fernival was an old lady not far
from 80 i should think
but i do not know she was thin and tall
and had a face as full of fine wrinkles
as if they had been drawn all over it
with a needle's point
her eyes were very watchful to make up i
suppose for her being so deaf as to be
obliged to use a trumpet
sitting with her working at the same
great piece of tapestry
was mrs stark her maid and companion and
almost as old as she was
she had lived with miss fernival ever
since they were both young
and now she seemed more like a friend
than a servant
she looked so cold and gray and stony as
if she had never loved or cared for
anyone
and i don't suppose she did care for
anyone except her mistress
and owing to the great deafness of the
latter mrs stark treated her very much
as if she were a child
mr henry gave some message from my lord
and then he bowed goodbye to us all
taking no notice of my sweet little miss
rosamond's outstretched hand
and left us standing there being looked
at by the two old ladies through their
spectacles
i was right glad when they rung for the
old footmen who had shown us in it first
and told him to take us to our rooms so
we went out of that great drawing room
and into another sitting room
and out of that and then up a great
flight of stairs and along a broad
gallery
which was something like a library
having books all down one side
and windows and writing tables all down
the other till we came to our rooms
which i was not sorry to hear were just
over the kitchens
for i began to think i should be lost in
that wilderness of a house
there was an old nursery that had been
used for all the little lords and ladies
long ago
with a pleasant fire burning in the
grate and the kettle boiling on the hob
and tea things spread out on the table
and out of that room was the night
nursery with a little crib for miss
rosamond close to my bed
and old james called up dorothy his wife
to bid us welcome
and both he and she were so hospitable
and kind
that by and by miss rosamond and me felt
quite at home
and by the time tea was over she was
sitting on dorothy's knee
and chattering away as fast as her
little tongue would go
i soon found out that dorothy was from
westmoreland and that bound her and me
together as it were
and i would never wish to meet with
kinder people than were old james and
his wife
james had lived pretty nearly all his
life in my lord's family
and thought there was no one so grand as
they he even looked down a little on his
wife
because till he had married her she had
never lived in any but a farmer's
household
but he was very fond of her as well he
might be they had one servant under them
to do all the rough work
agnes they called her and she and me and
james and dorothy
with miss fernival and mrs stark made up
the family
always remembering my sweet little miss
rosamond
i used to wonder what they had done
before she came they thought so much of
her now
kitchen and drawing room it was all the
same the hard sad miss fernival and the
cold mrs stark
looked pleased when she came fluttering
in like a bird
playing and pranking hither and thither
with a continual murmur
and pretty prattle of gladness i am sure
they were sorry many a time when she
flitted away into the kitchen
though they were too proud to ask her to
stay with them and were a little
surprised at her taste
though to be sure as mrs stark said it
was not to be wondered at
remembering what stock her father had
come of
the great old rambling house was a
famous place for little miss rosamund
she made expeditions all over it with me
at her heels
all except the east wing which was never
opened and whether we never thought of
going
but in the western and northern part was
many a pleasant room
full of things that were curiosities to
us that they might not have been to
people who had seen more
the windows were darkened by the
sweeping boughs of the trees
and the ivy which had overgrown them but
in the green gloom we could manage to
see old china jars and carved ivory
boxes
and great heavy books and above all the
old pictures
once i remember my darling would have
dorothy go with us
to tell us who they all were for they
were all portraits of some of my lord's
family
though dorothy could not tell us the
names of everyone
we had gone through most of the rooms
when we came to the old state drawing
room over the hall
and there was a picture of miss fernival
or as she was called in those days
miss grace for she was the younger
sister
such a beauty she must have been but
with such a set proud look
and such scorn looking out of her
handsome eyes with her eyebrows
just a little raised as if she wondered
how anyone could have the impertinence
to look at her
and her lip curled at us as we stood
there gazing
she had a dress on the like of which i
had never seen before
but it was all the fashion when she was
young a hat of some soft white stuff
like beaver
pulled a little over her brows and a
beautiful plume of feathers sweeping
rounded on one side
and her gown of blue satin was open in
front to a quilted white stomacher
well to be sure said i when i had gazed
my fill
flesh's grass they do say but who would
have thought that miss fernival had been
such an out-and-out beauty to see her
now
yes said dorothy folks change sadly
but if what my master's father used to
say was true
miss fernival the elder sister was
handsomer than miss grace
her picture is here somewhere but if i
show it to you
you must never let on even to james that
you have seen it
can the little lady hold her tongue do
you think has she
i was not so sure for she was such a
little sweet bold open-spoken child
so i set her to hide herself and then i
helped dorothy to turn a great picture
that leaned with its face towards the
wall and was not hung up as the others
were
to be sure it beat miss grace for beauty
and i think for scornful pride too
though in that matter it might be hard
to choose i could have looked at it an
hour
but dorothy seemed half-frightened at
having shown it to me
and hurried it back again and made me
run and find miss rosamund
for that there were some ugly places
about the house where she should like
ill for the child to go
i was a brave high-spirited girl and
thought little of what the old woman
said for i liked hide and seek as well
as any child in the parish
so off i ran to find my little one
as winter drew on and the days grew
shorter
i was sometimes almost certain that i
had heard a noise as if someone was
playing on the great organ in the hall
i did not hear it every evening but
certainly i did very often
usually when i was sitting with miss
rosamund after i had put her to bed
and keeping quite still and silent in
the bedroom then i used to hear it
booming and swelling away in the
distance
the first night when i went down to my
supper i asked dorothy who had been
playing music
and james said very shortly that i was a
gawk to take the wind softening among
the trees
for music but i saw dorothy look at him
very fearfully
and agnes the kitchen maid said
something beneath her breath
and went quite white i saw they did not
like my question
so i held my peace till i was with
dorothy alone when i knew i could get a
good deal out of her
so the next day i watched my time and i
coaxed and asked her who it was that
played the organ
for i knew that it was the organ and not
the wind well enough
for all i had kept silence before james
but dorothy had had her lesson all
warrant and never a word could i get
from her
so then i tried agnes though i had
always held my head rather above her
as i was even to james and dorothy and
she was a little better than their
servant
so she said i must never never tell and
if i ever told i was never to say
she had told me but it was a very
strange noise
and she had heard it many a time but
most of all on winter nights and before
storms
and folks did say it was the old lord
playing on the great organ in the hall
just as he used to do when he was alive
but who the old lord was
or why he played or why he played on
stormy winter evenings in particular
she either could not or would not tell
me
well i told you i had a brave heart and
i thought it was rather pleasant to have
that grand music rolling about the house
yet who would be the player for now it
rose above the great gusts of wind
and wailed and triumphed just like a
living creature
and then it fell to a softness most
complete only it was always music
and tunes so it was nonsense to call it
the wind i thought at first
that it might be miss fernival who
played unknown to agnes
but one day when i was in the hall by
myself i opened the organ and peeped all
about it and around it
as i had done to the organ and crossed
weight church once before
and i saw that it was all broken and
destroyed inside
though it looked so brave and fine and
then
though it was noon day my flesh began to
creep a little and i shut it up
and ran away pretty quickly to my own
bright nursery
and i did not like hearing the music for
some time after that
any more than james and dorothy did all
this time miss rosamund was making
herself more and more beloved
the old ladies liked her to dine with
them at their early dinner
james stood behind miss fernival's chair
an eye behind miss rosamond's all in
state
and after dinner she would play about in
a corner of the great drawing room
as still as any mouse while miss
fernival slept
and i had my dinner in the kitchen but
she was glad enough to come to me in the
nursery afterwards
for as she said miss fernival was so sad
and mrs stark so dull
but she and i were merry enough and by
and by
i got not to care for that weird rolling
music which did one no harm
if we did not know where it came from
that winter was very cold in the middle
of october the frosts began
and lasted many many weeks i remember
one day at dinner miss fernival lifted
up her sad heavy eyes
and said to mrs stark i am afraid we
shall have a terrible winter
in a strange kind of meaning way but mrs
stark pretended not to hear
and talked very loud of something else
my little lady and i did not care for
the frost
not we as long as it was dry we climbed
up the steep brows behind the house and
went up on the fells which were bleak
and bare enough
and there we ran races in the fresh
sharp air
and once we came down by a new path that
took us past the two
old gnarled holly trees which grew about
halfway down by the east side of the
house
but the days grew shorter and shorter
and the old lord
if it was he played away more and more
stormly and sadly
on the great organ one sunday afternoon
it must have been towards the end of
november i asked dorothy to take charge
of little missy when she came out of the
drawing room
after miss fernival had had her nap for
it was too cold to take her with me to
church
and yet i wanted to go and dorothy was
glad enough to promise
and was so fond of the child that all
seemed well
and agnes and i set off very briskly
though the sky hung heavy and black over
the white earth
as if the night had never fully gone
away and the air
though still was very biting and keen
we shall have a fall of snow said agnes
to me
and sure enough even while we were in
church it came down
thick in great large flakes so thick and
almost
dark in the windows it had stopped
snowing before we came out
but it lay soft thick and deep beneath
our feet as we tramped home
before we got to the hall the moon rose
and i think it was lighter then
what with the moon and what with the
white dazzling snow than it had been
when we went to church
between two and three o'clock i have not
told you that miss fernival and mrs
stark never went to church
they used to read the prayers together
in their quiet gloomy way
they seemed to feel the sunday very long
without their tapestry work to be busy
at
so when i went to dorothy in the kitchen
to fetch miss rosamund and take her
upstairs with me
i did not much wonder when the old woman
told me that the ladies had kept the
child with them
and that she had never come to the
kitchen as i had bidden her when she was
tired of behaving pretty in the drawing
room
so i took off my things and went to find
her and bring her to her supper in the
nursery
but when i went into the best drawing
room there sat the two old ladies
very still and quiet dropping out a word
now and then
but looking as if nothing so bright and
merry as miss rosamond had ever been
near them
still i thought she might be hiding from
me it was one of her pretty ways
and that she had persuaded them to look
as if they knew nothing about her
so i went softly peeping under this sofa
and behind that chair
making believe i was sadly frightened at
not finding her
what's the matter hester said mrs stark
sharply
i don't know if miss fernival had seen
me for as i told you she was very deaf
and she sat quite still idly staring
into the fire with her hopeless face
i'm only looking for my little rosy
posey replied i
still thinking that the child was there
and near me though i could not see her
miss rosamund is not here said mrs stark
she went away more than an hour ago to
find dorothy
and she too turned and went on looking
into the fire
my heart sank at this and i began to
wish i had never left my darling
i went back to dorothy and told her
james had gone out for the day
but she and me and agnes took lights and
went up into the nursery first
and then we roamed of the great large
house calling and entreating miss
rosamond to come out of her hiding place
and not frighten us to death in that way
but there was no answer
no sound oh said i at last can she have
gotten to the east wing and hidden there
but dorothy said it was not possible for
that she herself had never been in there
that the doors were always locked and my
lord steward had the keys she believed
at any rate neither she nor james had
ever seen them
so i said i would go back and see if
after all
she was not hidden in the drawing room
unknown to the old ladies
and if i found her there i said i would
whip her well for the fright she had
given me
but i never meant to do it well i went
back to the west drawing room and i told
mrs stark we could not find her anywhere
and asked for leave to look all about
the furniture there for i thought now
that she might have fallen asleep in
some warm hidden corner
but no we looked miss fernival got up
and looked
trembling all over and she was nowhere
there
then we set off again everyone in the
house and looked in all the places we
had searched before
but we could not find her miss fernival
shivered and shook so much
that mrs stark took her back into the
warm drawing room but not before they
had made me promise to bring her to them
when she was found
well a day i began to think she would
never be found when i both thought me to
look out into the great front court
all covered with snow i was upstairs
when i looked out
but it was such clear moonlight i could
see quite plain two little footprints
which might be traced from the hall door
and round the corner of the east wing
i don't know how i got down but i tugged
open the great stiff hall door
and throwing the skirt of my gown over
my head for a cloak
i ran out i turned the east corner and
there was a black shadow fell on the
snow
but when i came again into the moonlight
there were the little foot marks going
up
up to the fells it was bitter cold
so cold that the air almost took the
skin off my face as i ran
but i ran on crying to think how my poor
little darling must be perished and
frightened
i was within sight of the holly trees
when i saw a shepherd coming down the
hill
bearing something in his arms wrapped in
his mod
he shouted to me and asked me if i had
lost a baron
and when i could not speak for crying he
bore towards me
and i saw my wee bearny lying still and
white
and stiff in his arms as if she had been
dead
he told me he had been up the fells to
gather in his sheep
before the deep cold of night came on
and that under the holly trees black
marks on the hillside
where no other bush was for miles around
he had found my little lady
my lamb my queen my darling stiff and
cold
in the terrible sleep which is frost
begotten
oh the joy and the tears of having her
in my arms once again
for i would not let him carry her but
took her mod and all into my own arms
and held her near my own warm neck and
heart and felt the life stealing slowly
back again
into her little gentle limbs but she was
still insensible when we reached the
hall
and i had no breath for speech we went
in by the kitchen door
bring the warming pan said i and i
carried her upstairs and began
undressing her by the nursery fire
which agnes had kept up i called my
little lambie all the sweet and playful
names i could think of
even while my eyes were blinded by my
tears
and at last oh at length she opened her
large blue eyes
then i put her into her warm bed and
sent dorothy down to tell ms fernival
that all was well
and i made up my mind to sit by my
darling's bedside the live long night
she fell away into a soft sleep as soon
as her pretty head had touched the
pillow
and i watched by her till morning light
when she wakened up bright and clear
or so i thought at first and my dears so
i think now
she said that she had fancied that she
should like to go to dorothy
for that both the old ladies were asleep
and it was very dull in the drawing room
and that as she was going through the
west lobby she saw the snow through the
high window
falling falling soft and steady but she
wanted to see it lying pretty and white
on the ground
so she made her way into the great hall
and then going to the window
she saw it bright and soft upon the
drive but while she stood there
she saw a little girl not as old as she
was
but so pretty said my darling and this
little girl beckoned me to come out
i know she was so pretty and so sweet i
could not choose but go
and then this other little girl had
taken her by the hand
and side by side the two had gone round
the east corner
now you were a naughty little girl and
telling stories said i
and what would your good mama that is in
heaven and never told a story in her
life
say to her little rosamund if she heard
her and i dare say she does
telling stories indeed hester
sobbed out my child i'm telling you true
indeed i am
don't tell me said i very stern i
tracked you by your foot marks through
the snow
there were only yours to be seen and if
you had had a little
girl to go hand in hand with you up the
hill don't you think the footprints
would have gone along with yours
i can't help it dear dear hester said
she crying
if they did not i never looked at her
feet but she held my hand fast and tight
in her little one
and it was very very cold she took me up
the fell path
up to the holly trees and there i saw a
lady weeping and crying
but when she saw me she hushed her
weeping and smiled very proud and grand
and took me on her knee and began to
lull me to sleep
and that's all hester but that is true
and my dear mama knows it is
said she crying so i thought the child
was in a fever
and pretended to believe her as she went
over her story
over and over again and always the same
at last dorothy knocked at the door with
miss rosamond's breakfast
and she told me the old ladies were down
in the eating parlor and that they
wanted to speak to me
they had both been into the night
nursery the evening before but it was
after miss rosamund was asleep
so they had only looked at her not asked
me any questions
i shall catch it thought i to myself as
i went along the north gallery
and yet i thought taking courage it was
in their charge i left her and it's they
that's to blame for letting her steal
away unknown and unwatched
so i went in boldly and told my story i
told it all to miss fernival
shouting it close to her ear but when i
came to the mention of the other little
girl out in the snow
coaxing and tempting her out and her up
to the grand and beautiful lady by the
holly tree
she threw her arms up her old and
withered arms and cried aloud
oh heaven forgive have mercy
mrs stark took hold of her roughly
enough i thought
but she was past mrs stark's management
and spoke to me
in a kind of wild warning and authority
hester
keep her from that child it will lure
her to her death
that evil child tellered is a wicked
naughty child
then mrs stark hurried me out of the
room where indeed i was glad enough to
go
but miss fernival kept shrieking out oh
have mercy
well thou never forgive it is many a
long year ago
i was very uneasy in my mind after that
i never left miss rosamond night or day
for fear less she might slip off again
after some fancy or other
and all the more because i thought i
could make out the miss fernival was
crazy
from their odd ways about her and i was
afraid lest something of the same kind
which might be in the family you know
hung over my darling and the great frost
never ceased all this time
and whenever it was a more stormy night
than usual between the gusts and through
the wind
we heard the old lord playing on the
great organ
but old lord or not wherever miss
rosamund went
there i followed for my love for her
pretty helpless orphan
was stronger than my fear for the grand
and terrible sound
besides it rested with me to keep her
cheerful and merry as beseemed her age
so we played together and wandered
together here and there and everywhere
for i never dared to lose sight of her
again in that large and rambling house
and so it happened that one afternoon
not long before christmas day
we were playing together on the billiard
table in the great hall
not that we knew the right way of
playing but she liked to roll the smooth
ivory balls with her pretty hands
and i liked to do whatever she did and
by and by
without our noticing it it grew dusk
indoors though it was still light in the
open air
and i was thinking of taking her back
into the nursery when all of a sudden
she cried out
look hester look there's my poor little
girl out in the snow
i turned towards the long narrow windows
and there
sure enough i saw a little girl less
than my miss rosamund dressed all unfit
to be out of doors such a bitter night
crying and beating against the window
panes as if she wanted to be let in
she seemed to sob and wail till miss
rosamond could bear it no longer
and was flying to the door to open it
when all of a sudden
and close upon us the great organ peeled
out so loud and thundering it fairly
made me tremble
and all the more when i remembered that
even in the stillness of that dead cold
weather
i had heard no sound of little battering
hands upon the window glass
although the phantom child had seemed to
put forth all its force
and although i had seen it wail and cry
no faintest touch of sound had fallen
upon my ears
whether i remembered all this at the
very moment i do not know
the great organ sound had so stunned me
into terror
but this i know i caught up miss
rosamond before she got the hall door
opened and clutched her
and carried her away kicking and
screaming into the large bright kitchen
where dorothy and agnes were busy with
their mince pies
what is the matter with my sweet one
cried dorothy as i bore in miss rosamond
who was sobbing as if her heart would
break
she won't let me open the door for my
little girl to come in and she'll die if
she's out on the fells all night
cruel naughty hester she said slapping
me
but she might have struck harder for i
had seen a look of ghastly terror on
dorothy's face
which made my very blood run cold
shut the back kitchen door fast and bolt
it well said she to agnes
she said no more she gave me raisins and
almonds to quiet miss rosamond
but she sobbed about the little girl in
the snow and would not touch any of the
good things
i was thankful when she cried herself to
sleep in bed
then i stole down to the kitchen and
told dorothy i had made up my mind i
would carry my darling back to my
father's house and applethwaite
where if we lived humbly we lived at
peace
i said i had been frightened enough with
the old lord's organ playing
but now that i had seen for myself this
little moaning child
all decked out as no child in the
neighborhood could be
beating and battering to get in yet
always without any sound or noise
with the dark wound on its right
shoulder and that miss rosamond had
known it again for the phantom that had
nearly lured her to her death
which dorothy knew was true i would
stand it no longer
i saw dorothy change color once or twice
when i had done
she told me she did not think i could
take miss rosamond with me
for that she was my lord's ward and i
had no right over her
and she asked me would i leave the child
that i was so fond of
just for sounds and sights that could do
me no harm
and that they had all had to get used to
in their turns
i was all in a hot trembling passion and
i said it was very well for her to talk
that knew what these sights and noises
but tokened and that had perhaps had
something to do with the spectre child
while it was alive
and i taunted her so that she told me
all she knew at last
and that i wished i had never been told
for it only made me more afraid than
ever
she said she had heard the tale from old
neighbors that were alive when she was
first married
when folks used to come to the hall
sometimes before it had got such a bad
name on the countryside
it might not be true or it might what
she had been told
the old lord was miss furniture's father
miss grace as dorothy called her for
miss maud was the elder
and miss fernival by writes the old lord
was eaten up with pride
such a proud man was never seen or heard
of and his daughters were like him
no one was good enough to wed them
although they had choice enough
for they were the great beauties of
their day as i had seen by their
portraits where they hung in the state
drawing room
but as the old saying is pride will have
a fall
and these two haughty beauties fell in
love with the same man
and he no better than a foreign musician
whom their father had down from london
to play music with him at the manor
house
for above all things next to his pride
the old lord loved music
he could play on nearly every instrument
that ever was heard of
and it was a strange thing it did not
soften him but he was a fierce
dour old man and had broken his poor
wife's heart with his cruelty they said
he was mad after music and would pay any
money for it
so he got this foreigner to come who
made such beautiful music
that they said the very birds on the
trees stopped their singing to listen
and by degrees this foreign gentleman
got such a hold over the old lord
that nothing would serve him but that he
must come every year
and it was he that had the great organ
brought from holland and built up in the
hall where it stood now
he taught the old lord to play on it but
many and many a time
when lord fernival was thinking of
nothing but his fine organ and his finer
music
the dark foreigner was walking abroad in
the woods with one of the young ladies
now miss maude and then miss grace
miss maude won the day and carried off
the prize such as it was
and he and she were married all unknown
to anyone
and before he made his next yearly visit
she had been confined of a little girl
at a farmhouse on the moors
while her father and miss grace thought
she was away at doncaster races
but though she was a wife and a mother
she was not a bit softened
but as haughty and as passionate as ever
and perhaps more so
for she was jealous of miss grace to
whom her foreign husband paid a deal of
court
by way of blinding her as he told his
wife but miss grace triumphed over miss
maude
and miss maud grew fiercer and fiercer
both with her husband and with her
sister
and the former who could easily shake
off what was disagreeable
and hide himself in foreign countries
went away a month before his usual time
that summer and half threatened that he
would never come back again
meanwhile the little girl was left at
the farmhouse and her mother used to
have her horse saddled and galloped
wildly over the hills to see her once
every week at the very least
for where she loved she loved and where
she hated
she hated and the old lord went on
playing
playing on his organ and the servants
thought the sweet music he made had
soothed down his awful temper
of which dorothy said some terrible
tales could be told
he grew in firm too and had to walk with
a crutch
and his son that was the present lord
fernival's father
was with the army in america and the
other son at sea
so miss maud had it pretty much her own
way and she and miss grace grew colder
and bitterer to each other
every day till at last they hardly ever
spoke
except when the old lord was bi the
foreign musician came again the next
summer
but it was for the last time for they
led him such a life with their
jealousy and their passions that he grew
weary and went away
and never was heard of again and miss
maude who had always meant to have her
marriage acknowledged when her father
should be dead
was left now a deserted wife whom nobody
knew to have been married
with a child that she dared not own
although she loved it to distraction
living with a father whom she feared and
a sister whom she hated
when the next summer passed over and the
dark foreigner never came
both miss maude and miss grace grew
gloomy and sad
they had a haggard look about them
though they looked as handsome as ever
but by and by miss maud brightened for
her father grew more and more infirm
and more than ever carried away by his
music and she and miss grace lived
almost entirely apart
having separate rooms the one on the
west side miss maude on the east
those very rooms which were now shut up
so she thought she might have her little
girl with her and no one need ever know
except those who dared not speak about
it and were bound to believe that it was
as she said
a cottager's child she had taken a fancy
to
all this dorothy said was pretty well
known but what came afterwards no one
knew
except miss grace and mrs stark who was
even then her maid
and much more of a friend to her than
ever her sister had been
but the servant supposed from words that
were dropped
that miss maud had triumphed over miss
grace and told her that all the time the
dark foreigner had been mocking her with
pretended love
he was her own husband the color left
miss grace's cheek and lips that very
day forever
and she was heard to say many a time
that sooner or later
she would have her revenge and mrs stark
was forever spying about the east rooms
one fearful night just after the new
year had come in
when the snow was lying thick and deep
and the flakes were still
falling fast enough to blind anyone who
might be out and abroad
there was a great and violent noise
heard and the old lord's voice above
all cursing and swearing awfully and the
cries of a little child
and the proud defiance of a fierce woman
and the sound of a blow
and a dead stillness and moans and
wailings dying away on the hillside
then the old lord summoned all his
servants and told them with terrible
oaths
and words more terrible that his
daughter had disgraced herself and that
he had turned her out of doors
her and her child and that if ever they
gave her help
or food or shelter he prayed that they
might never enter heaven
and all the while miss grace stood by
him white and still as any stone
and when he had ended she heaved a great
sigh as much as to say her work was done
and her end was accomplished but the old
lord never touched his organ again
and died within the year and no wonder
for on the morrow of that wild and
fearful night
the shepherds coming down the fell side
found miss maude
sitting all crazy and smiling under the
holly trees
nursing a dead child with a terrible
mark on its right shoulder
but that was not what killed it dorothy
said it was the frost and the cold
every wild creature was in its hole and
every beast in its fold
while the child and its mother were
turned out to wander on the fells
and now you know all and i wonder if you
were less frightened now
i was more frightened than ever but i
said i was not
i wished miss rosamond and myself well
out of that dreadful house forever
but i would not leave her and i dared
not take her away but oh how i watched
her
and guarded her we bolted the doors and
shut the window shutters fast
an hour or more before dark rather than
leave them open
five minutes too late but my little lady
still heard the weird child
crying and mourning and not all we could
do or say
could keep her from wanting to go to her
and let her in from the cruel wind in
the snow
all this time i kept away from miss
fernival and mrs stark as much as ever i
could
for i feared them i knew no good could
be about them
with their gray hard faces and their
dreamy eyes
looking back into the ghastly years that
were gone
but even in my fear i had a kind of pity
for miss fernival at least
those gone down to the pit can hardly
have a more hopeless look than that
which was ever on her face
at last i even got so sorry for her who
never said a word but what was quite
forced from her
that i prayed for her and i taught miss
rosamond to pray for one who had done
a deadly sin but often when she came to
those words
she would listen and start up from her
knees and say
i hear my little girl planing and crying
very sad
oh let her in or she will die one night
just after new year's day had come at
last and the long winter had taken a
turn as i hoped
i heard the west drawing room bell ring
three times which was the signal for me
i would not leave miss rosamond alone
for all she was asleep
for the old lord had been playing wilder
than ever and i feared lest my darling
should waken to hear the spectre child
see her i knew she could not i had
fastened the windows too well for that
so i took her out of her bed and wrapped
her up in such outer clothes as were
most handy
and carried her down to the drawing room
where the old ladies sat at their
tapestry work as usual
they looked up when i came in and mrs
stark asked quite astounded
why did i bring miss rosamond there out
of her warm bed
i had begun to whisper because i was
afraid of her being tempted out while i
was away
by the wild child in the snow when she
stopped me short with a glance at miss
fernival
and said miss fernival wanted me to undo
some work she had done wrong
and which neither of them could see to
unpick so i laid my pretty deer on the
sofa
and sat down on a stool by them and
hardened my heart against them
as i heard the wind rising and howling
miss rosamond slept on sound for all the
wind blew so
and miss fernival said never a word nor
looked round when the gus
shook the windows all at once she
started up to her full height
and put up one hand as if to listen i
hear voices
said she i hear terrible screams i hear
my father's voice
just at that moment my darling awakened
with a sudden start
my little girl is crying oh how she is
crying and she tried to get up and go to
her
but she got her feet entangled in the
blanket and i caught her up
for my flesh had begun to creep at these
noises which they heard while we could
catch no sound
in a minute or two the noises came and
gathered fast
and filled our ears we too heard voices
and screams
and no longer heard the winter's wind
that raged abroad
mrs stark looked at me an eye at her but
we dared not speak
suddenly miss fernival went towards the
door and out into the anteroom
through the west lobby and opened the
door into the great hall
mrs stark followed and i durst not be
left though my heart almost stopped
beating for fear
i wrapped my darling tight in my arms
and went out with them
in the hall the screams were louder than
ever they sounded to come from the east
wing
nearer and nearer close on the other
side of the locked up rooms
close behind them then i noticed that
the great bronze chandelier seemed all a
light though the hall was dim
and that a fire was blazing in the vast
hearth place though it gave no heat
and i shuttered up with terror and
folded my darling closer to me
but as i did so the east door shook and
she
suddenly struggling to get free from me
cried hester
i must go my little girl is there i hear
her she is coming
hester i must go i held her tight with
all my strength
with a set will i held her if i had died
my hands would have grasped her still i
was so resolved in my mind
miss fernival stood listening and paid
no regard to my darling who had got down
to the ground
and whom i upon my knees now was holding
with both my arms clasped around her
neck
she still striving and crying to get
free
all at once the east door gave way with
a thundering crash
as if torn open in a violent passion and
there came into that broad and
mysterious light
the figure of a tall old man with gray
hair and gleaming eyes
he drove before him with many a
relentless gesture of abhorrence
a stern and beautiful woman with a
little child clinging to her dress
oh hester hester cried miss rosamond
it's the lady
the lady below the holly trees and my
little girl is with her
hester let me go to her they are drawing
me to them
i feel them i feel them i must go
again she was almost convulsed by her
efforts to get away
but i held her tighter and tighter till
i feared i should do her a hurt
but rather that then let her go towards
those terrible phantoms
they passed along towards the great hall
door where the winds howled and ravened
for their prey
but before they reached that the lady
turned and i could see that she defied
the old man with a fierce and proud
defiance
but then she quailed and then she threw
her arms wildly and piteously to save
her child
her little child from a blow from his
uplifted crutch and miss rosamond was
torn as by a power stronger than mine
and writhed in my arms and sobbed for by
this time the poor darling was growing
faint
they want me to go with them onto the
fells they are drawing me to them
oh my little girl i would come but cruel
wicked hester holds me very tight
but when she saw the uplifted crutch she
swooned away and i thanked god for it
just at this moment when the tall old
man his hair streaming as in the blast
of a furnace
was going to strike the little shrinking
child miss fernival
the old woman by my side cried out oh
father
father spare the little innocent child
but just then i saw
we all saw another phantom shape itself
and grow clear out of the blue and misty
light that filled the hall
we had not seen her till now for it was
another lady who stood by the old man
with a look of relentless hate and
triumphant scorn
that figure was very beautiful to look
upon with a soft white hat drawn down
over the proud brows
with a red and curling lip it was
dressed in an open robe of blue satin
i had seen that figure before it was the
likeness of miss fernival and her
youth and the terrible phantoms moved on
regardless of old miss vernal's wild
entreaty
and the uplifted crutch fell on the
right shoulder of the little child
and the younger sister looked on stony
and deadly serene
but at that moment the dim lights and
the fire that gave no heat
went out of themselves and miss fernival
lay at our feet stricken down by the
palsy
death stricken yes she was carried to
her bed that night
never to rise again she lay with her
face to the wall
muttering low but muttering always alas
alas what is done in youth can never be
undone in age
what is done in youth can never be
undone in age
you